souvenez-vous l'année dernière il y
avait eu une sécheresse historique dans
les prairies des feux de forêt
dramatiques en Colombie-Britannique
cette année heureusement ça a été un
petit peu plus tranquille même si il y a
eu certains rebondissements
[Musique]
dans l'Ouest canadien berceau de la
production céréalière au pays la saison
a commencé par une bonne frousse au
Manitoba la rivière Rouge est sortie de
son lit se transformant à bien des
endroits en lac comme ici chez Alain
Barnabé
d'embout puis certainement pas dans
l'eau toutes ces terres sont sous l'eau
sont bétail dans la boue
à l'aide d'une pompe il évacue l'eau à
l'extérieur de l'enclos le cultivateur
prévoyait semer du maïs mais les pluies
le force a changé
la première semaine
perdu juste pour attendre que l'eau
descend puis elle monte encore pour
avoir accès à l'assurance récolte les
semences doivent être plantés au plus
tard en juin la présence de l'eau qui
pourrait durer des semaines retarde les
semences le risque d'une mauvaise
récolte à l'automne est réel
au final malgré l'attente angoissante du
printemps l'été a déjoué les pronostics
et selon cette analyse on s'attend à de
beaux résultats dans l'Ouest cette année
sa nouvelle récolte qui envoie d'être
battu au moment où on se parle et
normale bonne peut-être même très bonne
dépendamment on aura les résultats plus
tard
dans l'est du pays la saison a aussi été
bonne pour les agriculteurs une région
fait toutefois exception le lac
Saint-Jean là-bas de fortes pluies en
mai et juin ont empêché les agriculteurs
d'entrer dans les champs avec la
machinerie David aussi produit plusieurs
céréales comme le blé l'orge et le
canola à Albanel à ce moment-ci du
printemps plus de 80% de ses chances
sont normalement semis mais cette année
c'est à peine 30%. il s'enlise
de plomberie
ça fait des bottes de terre le les roues
ça sautent les semis sont pas faites à
bonne profondeur c'est c'est tout est
affecté finalement ce sont plus de 4000
hectares qui n'ont pu être semés à temps
comme il s'agit d'un phénomène
climatique qui ne sait jamais produit
dans la région les contrats d'assurance
ne couvrent pas ce type de dommage et
les agriculteurs ne seront pas compensés
par la Financière agricole
et que la météo a été clémente ou pas
tous les agriculteurs ont dû faire face
à un même défi l'explosion des coûts de
production
comme c'est le cas ici chez des
producteurs de fraises des Laurentides
on est touché par le pétrole qui plus
que leur double toutes les plastiques
les engrais les pesticides tout en
remonté sa toute doublée et il faut
ajouter à cela la hausse du salaire
minimum qui fait grimper les coups de
main d'oeuvre chez fresbecq ça
représente 300000 dollars cette année on
est dans un tourbillon de dépenses qu'on
ne peut pas contrôler les producteurs
maraîchers qui doivent embaucher
beaucoup de travailleurs sont
particulièrement touchés mais les
problèmes liés à la main d'oeuvre ne
date pas d'hier ils existent depuis
plusieurs années déjà or un événement
récent contribue à la flambée des coûts
de production
la guerre en Ukraine le conflit a eu un
impact direct sur le prix du carburant
mais aussi sur celui de Denise essentiel
à l'alimentation humaine et animale les
grains monsieur Poutine a décidé
d'envahir l'Ukraine malheureusement le
24 février et là le marché à
littéralement paniqué
avec deux des principaux producteurs
mondiaux de grains désormais en guerre
l'incertitude s'installe et les prix
montant flèche ils atteignent des
sommets en mai
une bonne nouvelle pour les producteurs
agricoles qui vendent des céréales mais
rien pour réjouir les éleveurs qui
doivent en acheter pour nourrir leurs
animaux petite lueur d'espoir cependant
après les records du printemps le prix
des grains est revenu à peu près au
niveau où il se situait avant l'invasion
de l'Ukraine entre autres parce que
malgré la guerre les exportations de
grains de la région ce sont poursuivies
[Musique]
ont tout fait pour faire sortir leur
céréales du pays malgré des bouchons
monstres aux frontières et les Russes
n'ont jamais cessé leurs exportations
les producteurs agricoles ukrainiens ont
été vraiment très débrouillard il
réussissent malgré tout à récolter et
réussit sacheminer le grain
il faut se reporter au début du conflit
beaucoup de gens observateurs analysent
dans le milieu agricole on dit bon ben
c'est fini ces exportations agricoles de
l'Ukraine tomber à zéro tant et aussi
longtemps que la guerre va continuer à
mesure que l'offre de grâce est accrue
le marché a donc réagi à la baisse la
grande nouvelle sur le front agricole en
Ukraine ça a été la réouverture de trois
ports sur la mer Noire dont celui de
dessin
c'était un départ attendu après 5 mois
de guerre un premier navire transportant
des céréales ukrainiennes quittent le
port de dessin le razoni son équipage
prenne le large avec 26000 tonnes de
maïs à bord direction Tripoli ou Liban
le razzoni qui doit emprunter un
corridor de sécurité en pleine mer Noire
et chargée de deux denrées rares dit le
secrétaire général de l'ONU du maïs et
de l'espoir
de l'espoir pour des millions de gens
sur la planète qui dépendent des
céréales ukrainiennes pour survivre
explique-t-il et justement puisqu'il est
question de l'Ukraine nous avons repris
contact avec certains des agriculteurs
qui nous avaient raconté leur quotidien
en mars dernier on a voulu savoir
comment c'était déroulé leur été
grande culture
nous aurons un reportage complet le
premier octobre sur les fermiers
Ukrainiens en temps de guerre
de retour chez nous d'autres événements
ont marqué l'actualité agricole comme la
grève à l'usine d'agropure à Granby
2 millions de litres de lait gaspillés
en 5 jours dans cette ferme Raphaël
spany a dû se débarrasser de tout son
lait
à la poubelle c'est vraiment le fruit de
nos efforts qui qui est jeté directement
ça fait mal au cœur boire seul
fin juin les employés de l'usine
d'agropure à Granby ou près de 10% du
lait québécois est transformé on
déclenché une grève illimitée un conflit
qui a déstabilisé toute la filière
laitière pour éviter le gaspillage le
lait a été redirigé vers des usines
aussi loin que les Maritimes au coeur du
conflit les horaires de travail
l'employeur a finalement cédé sur cette
question la grève a pris fin début où
pour pallier la pénurie de main d'oeuvre
notamment dans le secteur
agroalimentaire où il manque 60 000
travailleurs le gouvernement fédéral a
annoncé ce printemps un assouplissement
des règles les usines de transformation
pourront désormais embaucher jusqu'à 30
% de travailleurs étrangers temporaires
plutôt que les 20% permis jusque-là la
nouvelle mesure doit être en vigueur
pendant un an mais déjà des voies
s'élèvent pour qu'elles perdurent
au-delà de 2023 au printemps un certain
manque d'intérêt pour les paniers bio et
l'achat local a aussi retenu l'attention
au jardin de la pointe à Trois-Rivières
les paniers de légumes n'ont pas été
aussi populaires qu'on l'aurait cru je
compare l'année dans le fond toutes les
abonnements étaient complets
puis justement vu qu'il y avait un gros
engouement en passant de décider de
faire plus de panique cette année mais
finalement on est resté au même nombre
parce que les gens ne sont pas ça m'a
rien inscrit
selon le réseau des fermiers de famille
la baisse des abonnements a finalement
été de 10% cet été cette diminution
arrive après plusieurs années de forte
croissance les abonnements avaient
notamment augmenté de 46%. en 2021
quand on envoie comme ça sur les côtes
parce que il y a un problème mais là
d'en voir autant c'est vraiment quelque
chose comme moi j'ai jamais vu on se
souviendra également de l'année 2022 en
raison de la grippe aviaire tout au long
du printemps et de l'été cette maladie a
semé la mort dans des élevages tout
comme dans la faune sauvage nous aurons
d'ailleurs un dossier complet sur le
sujet cet automne
j'annonce que le gouvernement du Canada
investi 45,3 millions de dollars pour
poursuivre nos efforts pour prévenir la
peste porcine africaine et se préparer à
réagir en cas d'éclosion
une autre maladie animale a retenu
l'attention cet été la peste porcine
africaine cette maladie hautement
contagieuse pour les pores mais
inoffensive pour les humains et toujours
absent du Canada et pour s'assurer
qu'elle le demeure le gouvernement
fédéral investit en prévention notamment
et en soutien au développement d'un
vaccin la maladie a décimé de nombreux
cheptels à travers le monde un seul cas
au Canada entraînerait la fermeture des
frontières à l'exportation une
catastrophe pour l'industrie car 70% du
port canadien est vendu à l'étranger
et ce bilan ne serait pas complet sans
un mot sur les événements climatiques
extrêmes le Canada a été relativement
épargné cet été mais ça n'a pas été le
cas notamment en Europe ou une vague de
chaleur sans précédent à balayer l'ouest
du continent
mais même s'il était ici n'a pas été
trop bouleversé le réchauffement
climatique se poursuit en coulissent
parlez-en au pêcheur de crevettes de
l'Atlantique ils ont vu leur quota de
pêche diminuer à nouveau cette année
depuis 2010 ces quotas ont été abaissés
de près de 60% car la ressource est en
déclin l'une des raisons le
réchauffement des eaux du Golfe la
petite crevette nordique aime l'eau
froide
[Musique]